enfin le procès verbal est adoptée sous
les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous rappelle que la séance est
retransmise en direct sur public sénat
et sur notre site internet au nom du
bureau du sénat
j'appelle chacun de vous mes chers
collègues a observé au cours de nos
échanges
l'une des valeurs essentielles du sénat
le respect qu'il s'agisse du respect des
hommes et des autres ou de celui du
temps de parole la parole est à monsieur
bernard bonne pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adressait à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture qui
malheureusement n'est pas ici alors
madame la ministre
trois ans après le discours de rungis la
situation des agriculteurs
particulièrement celle des producteurs
de viande bovine est catastrophique
pourtant il y croyait vraiment il
espérait qu'avec la loi et galim leur
avenir serait meilleur je rappelle que
cette loi devait rééquilibrer les
relations commerciales encadrer les
promotions et surtout redonner de la
valeur aux denrées agricoles
il n'en est rien l'annulation du salon
de l'agriculture pour cause de pandémie
nous oblige nous parlementaires a relayé
la détresse du monde rural
alors que 2020 est une année record des
bénéfices pour la grande distribution
que les négociations commerciales ont
été difficiles et ne se sont conclus que
dans la nuit de lundi à mardi
les revenus agricoles sont au plus bas
madame la ministre
comment se fait-il que l'obligation
contractuelle faisant référence aux
coûts de production
pourtant prévue par la loi ne soit pas
proposé aux producteurs et que les
entreprises de transformation
n'obtiennent pas de la grande
distribution un accord à cette hauteur
cette situation n'est ni moral ni
acceptable ni justifiable comment
comptez-vous y remédier merci monsieur
von la parole
ça madame olivier à grégoire secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'économie sociale
solidaire et responsable madame la
ministre
bonjour merci madame la présidente merci
de cet accueil chaleureux
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bonne c'est pour
une très bonne raison que notre mini
julien de normandie n'est pas là il est
excusé et je l'en excuses il est aussi
haut à l'assemblée nationale en ce
moment même ils sont excusés c'est en
son nom très directement que je vais me
permettre de vous répondre
et de saluer évidemment comme vous
l'avez fait la mobilisation totale de
notre chaîne alimentaire
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour vous
annoncer que le premier ministre ira
dans les prochains jours aux côtés de
nos éleveurs pour leur témoigner très
concrètement la reconnaissance que leur
doit notre gouvernement la loi et galim
de 2018 a mis en place des outils très
concrets pour parvenir à cet objectif il
y a encore du chemin c'est pourquoi nous
continuons à surveiller cinq réunions de
comité de suivi des négociations
commerciales ont eu lieu depuis ces
derniers mois menée par julien de
normandie notamment une mission a été
confiée à serge papin qui doit dresser
des pistes d'amélioration vous le savez
la transparence c'est la clé pour
surmonter l'opposition entre
distributeurs et industriels
nous continuons à mener à bien
l'application des galim d'abord bruno le
maire intensifie démultiplie les
contrôles pour que la loi et dialyse
soit effectivement appliqué ensuite nous
renforçons la médiation nous savons
qu'elle est indispensable
enfin nous avons lancé une adresse de
signalements pour mobiliser les
consommateurs et lutter contre des prix
trop bas ou des indications trompeuses
notamment sur l'origine plusieurs cas
pour votre information sont déjà
traitées par les services du ministère
de l'agriculture et de la dgccrf
en un mot cher sénateur c'est chaque
jour nous continuons à nous mobiliser
pour répondre aux constats collectif
fait ensemble lors des ateliers et galim
merci encore de votre accueil chaleureux
et j'espère que cette réponse vous aura
convaincu
si madame la ministre la parole et sam
s'il vous plaît la parole est à monsieur
bonne pour tous genres et bon mais je
regrette beaucoup madame la mise ce type
de réponse qui ne correspond en rien à
ce qui ce qu'on voit sur le terrain
j'étais je vais vous prendre un exemple
j'étais il n'y a pas très longtemps la
semaine dernière avec un groupe
d'agriculteurs dans mon département de
la loire il y avait un agriculteur qui
me disait que sa fille lui avait demandé
sa feuille d'imposition et lorsqu'elle
est revenu quelques minutes après la dit
comment ça se fait papa il ya zéro sur
les revenus de ton taf et d'imposition
il lui a expliqué qu'effectivement c'est
un agriculteur qui était là depuis 17
ans qui travaillait normalement qui
avait plus d'endettement qui touchait
même un peu de pub de la pac
trente mille euros à peu près qu'ils
avaient en effet soumises les compteurs
et qu' il n'était pas capable n'était
pas capable d'amener une réponse
positive à sa fille je crois qu'il faut
arrêter
mais ce niveau des agriculteurs la
question est terminée
de faire en sorte qu'il n'y en ait plus
en france et surtout qu'on puisse
remplir nos assiettes human avec
d'autres avec d'autres nourritures que
celles qui viennent de la france
la parole est à madame christine herzog
pour le groupe union centriste pour les
yeux madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre jean-marie
maison mon collègue de moselle s'associe
aussi pour vous poser la question hier
matin à minuit pour la seconde fois en
moins d'un an le gouvernement fédéral
d'angela merkel a mis fin à 60 ans de
relations transfrontalières entre le
département de la moselle et ces deux
länder allemand voisin de sarre et de
rhénanie-palatinat
selander ont manifesté leur
mécontentement suite à cette rupture
brutale des accords et traités relatifs
à la libre circulation des personnes et
des marchandises en cause à taux
d'incidence trop élevé de la circulation
du coc vie 19 et de ces variants en
moselle et c'est sur ce point que la
prise de décision allemande pose
problème d'abord il a été constaté et
relevé que les länder allemands des
pistes quatre fois moins de personnes
que les départements français et pour
cause le test co-éco vide et payant en
allemagne donc mécaniquement si on
cherche pas on ne trouve pas les
statistiques sont à leur faible 80 cas
pour 100000 habitants en ça mais grimpe
aussitôt si on ne teste en masse comme
en moselle 284% mille le 28 février
ensuite les mesures drastiques décidées
sont inapplicables car l'allemagne ne
veut pas fournir les tests des seize
mille travailleurs frontaliers français
car l'allemagne l'exigent et les fera
payer tous les deux jours la france ne
dispose pas non plus car ils doivent
être tous négatifs est valable
uniquement 48 heures pour rejoindre
l'allemagne l'allemagne se moque de nous
pour les enfants ce encore plus
dramatique qui peut exiger qu'un enfant
de plus de 6 ans scolarisés en allemagne
mais vivent en france fasse un test
antigénique où paissaient ravec
écouvillon tous les deux tous les deux
jours c'est très douloureux
ils sont mille dans ce cas là et c'est
inacceptable
nous sommes transparents mais
l'allemagne doit l'être aussi
tous nos efforts commencent à payer nous
sommes passés de
471 cas confié confirmé de kobe de 27
février à 124 le 1er mars en moselle
chaque année de nouvelles cultures
oui vite fait le truc monsieur le
premier ministre le chef de l'état at-il
engagé avec l'allemagne un dialogue
visant à s'aligner sur des règles
identiques comme le décompte des cas
d'hospitalisation chocolat et peut- on
exiger qu'un test salivaire pour les
enfants mais remercie avant de donner la
parole à monsieur clément donne
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
j'attire votre attention chacun et
chacune de mes collègues en un temps de
parole limité veuillez s'il vous plaît
ici le respecté pour que chacun puisse
poser sa question dans de bonnes
conditions
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice herzog
vous l'avez rappelé dimanche l'allemagne
a annoncé le classement du département
de la moselle en zone à risque au titre
de la circulation à des variants nous
l'avons dit c'est une décision que nous
regrettons comme vous parce qu'elle ne
tient pas compte des nécessités des
exigences d'un bassin de vie
sur le plan scolaire sur le plan du
travail sur le plan de la vie
quotidienne nous avons néanmoins tout au
long de la semaine et nous poursuivons
cet effort mené une étroite coordination
à tous les niveaux les locaux les
exécutifs départementaux et régionaux le
gouvernement et le prêt de la république
lui-même avec la chancelière merkel nous
avons mené cette concertation avec
l'allemagne pour éviter les conséquences
les plus dures de ce classement
je rappelle que automatiquement ce
classement a abouti avec les voisins
autrichiens et chèque de l'allemagne à
une fermeture complète des frontières
c'est une situation que nous avons voulu
éviter à l'égard de la moselle compte
tenu de la réalité que vous rappeliez
notamment pour les seize mille
travailleurs qui quotidiennement ont
besoin de franchir la frontière pour
exercer leur activité professionnelle
nous avons pu contenir l'impact de ce
classement en permettant que des tests
antigénique et non pcr soit obligatoire
n'ont pas tous les 24 heures comme
c'était prévu mais tous les 48 heures
nous sommes aussi en train de déployer
plus de tests à
avec les autorités de stars en
particulier du côté français comme du
côté allemand
et nous avons aussi fait en sorte je
crois que c'est à la fois symbolique et
nécessaire sur le plan pratique que les
contrôles ne soit pas effectués
systématiquement et sur les points de
passage aux frontières pour éviter les
ralentissements supplémentaires je
reconnais que la situation n'est pas
encore satisfaisante et cette
concertation doit se poursuivre je serai
demain je poursuivrai la concertation
avec vous même comme les faits ce week
end
tout le long à mesure des informations
que nous obtenions je serai demain en
moselle pour poursuivre ce travail et
continuerait avec vous avec les
autorités allemandes a essayé de prendre
en compte au mieux la situation pratique
pour les enfants pour leurs parents pour
les travailleurs frontaliers nous les
avons bien en tête à coeur et nous
continuerons ce travail
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
madame cécile kuperman pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et que le
gist chaque collègue
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues vous avez
relancé hier la concertation pour votre
réforme de l'assurance chômage
à l'unanimité les organisations
syndicales la rougette mais vous
persistez dans votre obstination à
aggraver la précarité des plus fragiles
dans notre pays
vous annoncez ainsi vouloir faire plus
d'un milliard trois d'économies sur le
dos des demandeurs d'un poids oserais-je
vous rappeler qu'ils ne sont pas les
responsables de leur situation
depuis des mois en pleine crise
sanitaire les plans de licenciements se
multiplient de partout dans notre pays
face à cette crise sociale qui s'aggrave
votre réponse est repoussée d'un an le
bonus malus pour les entreprises
imposé dès le 1er juillet la baisse de
20% des indemnités journalières à plus
de 830 mille demandeurs d'emploi on est
finalement bien
du et en même temps de 2017 depuis
plusieurs mois la pauvreté s'accroît
dans notre pays
les restaurants du coeur le secours
populaire le secours catholique nous
alertent quotidiennement les files
d'attentes s'allongent pour la
distribution alimentaire semaine après
semaine la crise sanitaire ne peut être
un justificatif à cette réforme
alors oui madame la ministre quand allez
vous renoncer à votre réforme inique de
l'assurance chômage
merci chers collègues la parole et à
madame elisabeth bornes ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice qui kerman sans surprise nous
ne sommes pas d'accord sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage mais je ne peux pas
laisser dire que le gouvernement n'agit
pas massivement pour lutter contre la
précarité
je vous rappelle que nous avons prolongé
par exemple les droits des demandeurs
d'emploi depuis le mois de novembre en
mobilisant près de 1,5 milliard d'euros
je rappelle également que nous avons mis
en place une garantie de revenus de 900
euros par mois pour les travailleurs
précaires nous avons mis en place cette
aide exceptionnelle depuis le mois de
novembre et nous avons décidé de la
prolonger jusqu'à fin mai ce sont plus
de 460 mille demandeurs d'emploi qui
bénéficient de cette aide pour laquelle
nous mobilisons 1,2 milliard d'euros
je rappelle également que pour lutter
contre la précarité nous mobilisons
l'activité partielle depuis le début de
la crise qui a protégé 9 millions de
salariés au plus fort de la crise et
encore 2 millions et encore 2 millions
en janvier dernier et sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage le gouvernement a
pleinement pris en compte le contexte
sanitaire économique et social nous
avons fait des adaptations très forte
pour répondre aux observations des
organisations syndicales avec notamment
le maintien du seuil d'ouverture des
droits à quatre mois tant que la
situation sur le marché du travail n'est
pas revenue à la normale
ou encore nous avons mis en place un
plancher dans le calcul de l'allocation
chômage pour éviter les allocations trop
basse donc vous voyez madame la
sénatrice
j'ai la conviction que cette réforme
assure le meilleur équilibre possible
sur l'assurance-chômage dans la
rien d'actuel jour merci merci madame la
ministre
la parole est à m puis kerman pour les
répliques vous avez bon quarante et une
madame la ministre je vous pose une
question sur la réforme à venir vous
m'expliquer que heureusement dans la
cinquième puissance mondiale
nous n'avons pas laisser mourir les gens
que nous avons mis en place des mesures
d'urgence pendant cette crise sanitaire
que personne n'a souhaité et oui dans
ces mesures d'urgence nous avons
protéger l'activité économique
les femmes et les hommes qui au
quotidien continue de travailler c'est
bien normal ce n'est pas le moment de se
dire merci ce que vous proposez c'est
d'aggraver dès le 1er juillet la
situation de ces femmes et de ces hommes
qui aujourd'hui perdre leur emploi
madame la ministre vous avez déclaré il
ya peu que vous étiez une femme de
gauche attac est attaché injustices
sociales et bien la réforme que vous
proposez n'est pas une réforme de gauche
et une réforme de gauche s'est tiré les
droits vers le haut et ne pas aller
tirer les abc vers le bas c'est
finalement avec ses politiques que l'on
fera procès l'extrême droite dans notre
pays
ce ne sera pas de la responsabilité des
éleveurs de bauchi l'as far 1
c'est monsieur julien dangereux tant
pour le foot rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendant
merci mais à la présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame brigitte bourguignon
face à l'évolution des variants
contrastée selon les territoires
le gouvernement a choisi une gestion
territorialisée de la pandémie justifiée
par les différences existantes entre les
zones géographiques
ma question vise à vous demander un
bilan des premières remontées de la
concertation qui était déjà largement
engagé et qui s'approfondit des maires
ont fait parvenir des suggestions
intéressantes et utiles
les derniers jours ont cependant plutôt
été marquée par la volte face
spectaculaire de la maire de paris qui
pétri de certitudes a demandé un
confinement strict de trois semaines
pour tour ouvrir ensuite puis transformé
puis transformé cette cette affirmation
catégorique en simple hypothèse pour
enfin dire qu'il n'en avait été jamais
question tout cela en quatre jours tout
cela en quatre jours ajoutant la faute
politique à la faute professionnelle les
élus de tous bords et y compris du sien
partout en france se sont réfugiés dans
un silence assourdissant dont je sais
qu'il est en réalité réprobateur
sénateur de paris je le dis j'ai été
très choquée que jamais
n'ait été concerté ni les maires
d'arrondissement ni les maires
d'arrondissement ni les élus franciliens
comme si paris était une citadelle est
que le virus allait s'arrêter à ces
portes cassées à ses portes
donc 7,7 we7 cette épidémie
cette épidémie nécessite exige d'être
solidaire et non pas un exercice du
pouvoir qui est solitaire surtout
surtout quand on attaque la verticalité
madame la ministre madame la ministre au
moment où il faut être à la hauteur des
enjeux
humilité et responsabilité unités
bargeton
calé quel est le bilan
le temps de retirer ou les horizons
fusion car en tirer des premières
remontées des élus locaux
mais s'ils sont sérieux la parole est à
madame brigitte bourguignon ministre
délégué chargé de l'autonomie s'il vous
plaît chers collègues si l'on pouvait
poursuivre cette créance dans le calme
ce serait bien
écoutons nous s'il vous plaît merci
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur julien bargeton je vous
remercie pour cette question qui me
permet qui me permet de rappeler s'il en
était besoin la situation sanitaire dans
notre pays
qu'il est loin d'être amusante qui
demeure particulièrement préoccupante
d'ailleurs nous occupons près de 22
mille nouveaux cas déclarés chaque jour
en moyenne un nombre de patients en
réanimation qui augmente
près de 71% des lits en réanimation sont
occupés par des patients atteints de ce
virus et surtout les variants comptes
qui progressent le taux d'incidence
remonte partout mais la situation est
particulièrement préoccupante à mayotte
à la réunion en ile-de-france dans les
hauts de france dans la région paca ce
que nous suivons de très près avec
olivier ferrand
nous déployons à cette fin un arsenal de
mesures visant à briser la dynamique
épidémique le suivi des cas contactez le
respect de l'isolément des patients des
cas contactez nous accompagnons ces
collectivités impacté par des mesures de
gestion dédiée la vaccination s'accélère
elle présente de très beaux résultats en
ehpad près de 80 % des résidents ayant
reçu la première dose
la campagne s'accélère aussi pour nos
concitoyens les plus âgés et les plus
jeunes qui présentent des facteurs de
risque
néanmoins nous devons prendre la mesure
du moment rester vigilant collectivement
cette vigilance s'exerce au quotidien
par le respect des gestes barrières le
port du masque lorraine le lavage des
mains le recours au télétravail quand
c'est possible
nos concitoyens ont consenti à de
nombreux sacrifices qui ne saurait être
bafoué sur l'autel d'enjeux partisans
dans un esprit de concorde nous
non à consulter associer les
collectivités concernées pour
l'élaboration des réponses les plus
adéquates en phase avec les dynamiques
territoriales
les français sont en attente de clarté
sur des décisions nous agissons donc en
responsabilité merci merci madame la
ministre
la parole est à la dame marie pierre de
la gontrie pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains voulaient ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
pour la première fois dans notre
histoire récente
un ancien président de la république a
été condamné à trois années
d'emprisonnement pour corruption active
et pour trafic d'influencé par le
tribunal correctionnel quelques heures
plus tard
votre ministre de l'intérieur a alors
d'un déplacement officiel indiqué je
cite nicolas sarkozy en ces moments
difficiles a évidemment tout mon soutien
lorsque le ministre de l'intérieur
s'exprime face caméra en déplacement
officiel
ce n'est pas un propos privés c'est la
position du gouvernement
alors monsieur le premier ministre la
question est simple partagez vous les
propos de votre ministre de l'intérieur
et considérez vous qu'il soit compatible
avec sa fonction
monsieur monsieur gabriel a tall
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre porte parole du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice marie pierre de la gontrie
vous êtes une spécialiste des questions
institutionnelles et des questions
judiciaires et vous savez donc qu'en
tant que membre du gouvernement je n'ai
pas de commentaire à faire sur une
décision de justice il ya une séparation
des pouvoirs un état de droit vous avez
cité les propos de gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur je regrette que
vous n'ayez pas citer l'intégralité de
la phrase que vous avez sélectionné un
bout de la phrase gérald darmanin a
commencé par dire je n'ai pas de
commentaire à faire sur une décision de
justice
il l'a dit
très clairement il l'a dit on ne peut
plus clairement et il est ensuite à
titre personnel des mots amicaux pour
une personne qui le connaît c'est tout à
fait son droit et sa possibilité mais
l'important c'est que l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement et d'ailleurs
depuis le début de ce quinquennat
à chaque fois que nous sommes amenés à
être interrogés ou à devoir réagir sur
des affaires judiciaires nous nous en
tenons à une ligne en permanence et a
fortiori quand il s'agit d'un ancien
président de la république comme pour
tout autre justiciable nous en tenons
nous en tenons à une ligne qui est de ne
pas commenter une décision de justice ce
qu'a rappelé gérald darmanin dans ses
propos si monsieur ministre mesdames de
la gontrie vous avez la parole pour une
minute 15
monsieur le premier ministre votre
silence est éloquent
vous avez souhaité ne pas répondre et
finalement nous ne serons pas si vous
partagez ou non les propos du ministre
de l'intérieur j'ai tendance pour ma
part car je vous fais confiance sur ce
point à penser que vous manifestez ainsi
votre réprobation
vous avez monsieur promis nice décidé
d'inscrire à l'agenda du gouvernement
un texte qui sera présenté par le garde
des sceaux qui s'appelle rétablir la
confiance dans la justice
de la même manière nous allons débattre
dans quelques jours dans cet hémicycle
d'un texte sur le respect des principes
de la république
mais lorsqu'on a l'honneur de participer
à un gouvernement on doit chérir la
constitution et on doit chérir les
principes de la république parmi
lesquels le respect de la loi et le
respect de l'indépendance de l'autorité
judiciaire comment ne pas voir l'effet
dévastateur de l'expression publique
d'un soutien annulaire
adressée par le patron des policiers à
une personne lourdement condamnés pour
des manquements à la probité
monsieur premier ministre nul ne peut se
réjouir de voir un ancien président de
la république condamné pour corruption
mais tous nous devrions nous réjouir
d'avoir une justice qui s'applique à
tous puissants misérable nous devrions
au terme de notre constitution chérir
l'indépendance de l'autorité judiciaire
dans le présente dans le public et le
garant il semble nécessaire aux journées
le féminisme que vous le rappeliez à
lettre au ministre de l'intérieur
merci la parole est à madame ghislaine
fontaine pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
transports monsieur le ministre
ma question porte sur l'avenir des
lignes de desserte fine inter-régional
béziers clermont ferrand paris et nîmes
clairement paris qui comme vous le savez
desservent la lozère plus spécial
hommage
j'interviendrai sur la ligne dite de
l'aubrac l'état et la région occitanie
travaille actuellement à un protocole
relatif aux lignes de desserte fine du
territoire de ladite région
cet accord doit permettre de
matérialiser les engagements respectifs
de l'état de la sncf de la région
vous avez souhaité exclure les lignes de
l'aubrac et des cévennes de ce protocole
afin de les traiter d un accord inter
régionale ultérieure asocial la région
auvergne et rhône alpes
ce choix de report renforce des
inquiétudes sur les intentions du
gouvernement concernant la ligne de
l'aubrac
actuellement elle est interrompue pour
une durée indéterminée et l'on sait que
des travaux d'urgence sommet sont
nécessaires au maintien du transport
ferroviaire
cette ligne monsieur le ministre est
essentiel pour la lozère et le sud du
massif central
d'abord parce qu'elle relie comme le
cévenol la lozère notre capitale ensuite
monsieur le ministre nous ne sommes pas
des sous citoyens nous avons droit comme
tous les français à des infrastructures
qui nous permettent de rejoindre paris
en un temps raisonnable
ensuite parce que la ligne de l'aubrac
achemine de nombreux lycéens et
étudiants vers leur lieu de formation et
assure le fonctionnement et la viabilité
d'une des dernières
in sidérurgique française entreprises
innovantes dans le domaine des aciers
électriques haut de gamme
enfin parce qu'elle donne accès à
l'aubrac à des centaines de touristes
chaque année
ma question monsieur le ministre vous
l'aurez compris est triple où en est
cette convention que contiendra tels
quels sont les engagements de l'état et
de la sncf pour satisfaire les besoins
urgents d'investissement en matière de
régénération de cette vigne quelle est
l'ambition de l'état pour leur
pérennisation à long terme des
circulations fret et voyageurs sur cette
ligne
merci merci madame france elle la parole
est à monsieur jean baptiste djebbari
ministre délégué chargé des transports
merci au président koné faisait
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
vous m'interrogez sur la desserte du
massif central ce qui me permet de
revenir brièvement sur la politique du
gouvernement en matière ferroviaire
comme vous le savez en 2017 nous avons
concentré notre action sur les lignes du
quotidien en suspendant pour un temps
les grands projets de manière à assainir
d'abord la situation financière de la
sncf avec 35 milliards de dettes
reprises de réinvestir massivement sur
le réseau ferroviaire + 3 milliards par
an et d'engager le sauvetage des petits
team ferroviaire en lien avec les
régions pour un volume de 6 milliards 6
milliards 5,2 euros pour pérenniser ses
9000 kilomètres de petites ligues au
combien essentielle pour nos territoires
nous avons et vous l'avez évoqué
commencé à négocier deux contrats avec
la région auvergne relate l'un signé il
ya quelques semaines en présence du
premier ministre de manière à assurer la
pérennité des neuf lignes ferroviaires
dovan rhône-alpes tout en dégageant des
crédits d'urgence pour assurer les 130
millions de travaux d'ici à 2022 dans le
même temps j'ai souhaité avoir cette
discussion que vous avez évoquées au
niveau interrégional occitanie auvergne
rhône-alpes sous l'égide du préfet
philizot sur les lignes de l'aubrac et
du cévenol de manière à conclure d'ici à
mi mai un engagement réciproque entre
l'état sncf réseau et les deux régions
concernées tout en nation dans la même
façon les travaux d'urgence que nous
assurons notamment sur la ligne entre
chez ea d'objets et nous ça vous pouvez
compter madame la sénatrice sur le total
engagement du gouvernement
merci
seul ministre madame comptait livrer
cette seconde si vous avez deux mots à
dire l'étude d'itinéraires envisage non
pardon au delà d'un engagement financier
ponctuel ma question porte bien sur
l'engagement à long terme de l'état et
au delà du grand paris via la france
chaque territoire mérite
l'investissement de l'état merci madame
fanzel la parole aux aveux sur ronan
dantec pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoires merci madame
la présidente ma question ne s'adressait
pas spécialement aux me lisent les
transports ce week-end pour sa dernière
session
la convention citoyenne pour le climat a
très sévèrement noté la manière dont le
gouvernement a traduit dans la loi ces
propositions malgré l'engagement du
président de la république
les déclinaisons sans filtre les travaux
de cette convention citoyenne
le gouvernement a décidé de les repasser
à la moulinette hachant menu très menue
l'ambition initiale et le mandat donné
au 150 citoyens
ainsi alors que nous savons qu'il faut
dix ans pour que nos décisions
politiques aboutissent à des réduction
significative des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre vous décidé aujourd'hui
que la france n'honorera pas en 2030
ni l'accord de paris ni l'objectif
européen de réduction de 55 % des
émissions de co2 objectif que vous avez
pourtant soutenu lors du conseil
européen du 11 décembre dernier
faut-il le rappeler le saisit le conseil
d'état où le haut conseil pour le climat
pointent tous
l'insuffisance du projet de loi et ses
incohérences le haut conseil du climat
contenu même que ce texte permettra au
mieux 20 % de réduction des émissions en
ma question est donc 5 monsieur le
ministre en novembre prochain
l'aco 26 sera consacrée au rehaussement
de l'ambition comment comptez-vous donc
assumer à glasgow cet adieu français à
l'accord de paris que nous avions
pourtant portée et via six ans par une
mobilisation exceptionnelle de notre
diplomatie
merci monsieur dantec la parole est à
monsieur jean baptiste djebbari ministre
délégué chargé des transports
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur monsieur le sénateur dantec
vous interrogez madame barbe à pop
illiquides ne pouvant être présentes m'a
chargé de vous répondre
tiens d'abord à rappeler le caractère
totalement inédit de démocratie
participative qui a permis sous
l'impulsion du président de la
république à 150 citoyens à la fois de
se construire une vision personnelle et
de faire des propositions très concrètes
pour remplir les objectifs que vous avez
évoqué là qui nous permettre
effectivement d'être sur cette marche
ils étaient 2 degrés que nous
considérons comme tout à fait essentiel
nous avons longuement et continûment
échanger avec les citoyens ceux ci ont
rendu un jugement sur l'action du
gouvernement toute indépendance il
appartient maintenant au parlement de se
saisir du texte et de remplir sa
fonction au nom du peuple français
parmi les 149 mesure de la ccc un grand
nombre a déjà été mises en oeuvre par
voie réglementaire et par d'autres
canaux notamment par la voie des
initiatives européennes
à titre d'exemple au ministère des
transports sur l'e42 mesures proposées
25 sont déjà à l'oeuvre ont été mises en
oeuvre par voie réglementaire et 14 sont
intégrées dans le projet doit de la
convention citoyenne nous avons pu ainsi
avancer sur des sujets majeurs je pense
notamment à la conversion du parc
automobile qui aura des impacts et des
résultats très significatifs en termes
de baisse des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre à la création de 35 zones à
faibles émissions qui permettent là
aussi de lutter contre la pollution de
l'air dans les zones les plus densément
peuplées ou encore à la multiplication
du plan vélo que je sais vous appelez de
vos voeux
notre vision est simple nous agissons en
complémentarité des modes de transport
et nous en concurrence nous organisons
l'équité entre les territoires et nous
mettons en oeuvre des transitions
industrielle dans le souci de justice
sociale tant vous savez que certains
secteurs subissent des mutations
extrêmement profonde
votre action vous ce sénateur elle est
inédite elle est résolue elle est
responsable
nous sommes fiers de porter cette action
nous sommes convaincus qu'elle portera
des résultats tangibles et rapide je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
dantec vous avez la parole pour 33
secondes
oui monsieur vous avez pas échappé que
ma question était sur la stratégie
diplomatique de la france à glasgow
donc un petit rappel glasgow s'annonce
aujourd'hui avec des engagements
extrêmement ambitieux des américains des
japonais et même des chinois et que nous
allons être la première
grande puissance industrielle arrivé à
glasgow après le vote de sa propre loi
en disant clairement nous ne tiendrons
pas les engagements
c'est une position qui est intenable sur
la scène internationale et pour conclure
monsieur le premier ministre une petite
confidence je suis un ayatollah liste
c'est à dire que je respecte je cherche
à appliquer par la loi
les engagements internationaux de la
france merci chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur daniel
chassaing pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
[Musique]
madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur me lisent
l'intérieur mes chers collègues le 2
novembre 2020 l'administration centrale
au ministère de l'intérieur adressé un
message à tous les directeurs du 6
indiquant le lancement d'une réflexion
pour un décret d'encadrement de
l'activité des sapeurs pompiers
volontaires sans que ceux-ci soient
consultés ils représentent pourtant 79 %
des effectifs
en effet en rapport avec la directive
européenne de 2003 concernant certains
aspects de l'aménagement du temps de
travail
cette missive indique que les sapeurs
pompiers volontaires pourraient être
considérées comme supplétifs de fait et
risque donc d'être assimilés à des
professionnels
cela irait en compte du refus de
transposer la directive aux sapeurs
pompiers volontaires qui est défendu
depuis 2003 par tous les parlementaires
et tous les gouvernements la loi du 20
janvier 2011 est très précise et indique
l'activité des sapeurs pompiers
volontaires qui repose sur le
volontariat et le bénévolat n'est pas
exercée à titre professionnel en 2019
j'avais interrogé le secrétaire d'état
mme ce nu mais ce qu'ils avaient fait
une réponse claire en indiquant que les
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires ne seraient
pas assimilés à des salariés deux ans
après donc cette missive entraîne une
forte inquiétude chez sapeurs pompiers
volontaires
les départements les élus les dix
l'organisation de la sécurité dans le
monde rural serait menacé
en désorganisant totalement en fonction
des dix 10 avec une dégradation des
délais des secours et la disparition
progressive
de ce service public solidaire monsieur
le ministre vous nous avez vous nous
aviez promis une action au niveau
européen la france assurera la
présidence tournante du conseil européen
à partir de janvier
pouvez-vous nous assurer que la question
des sapeurs pompiers volontaires sera à
l'ordre du jour est enfin réglé
merci chers collègues la parole est à
mme marlène schiappa ministre délégué
chargé de la citoyenneté
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés les sénateurs
parlerons je prie de m'excuser les
sénateurs et monsieur le sénateur daniel
chassaing comme vous le pointer très
justement dans votre question le
ministère de l'intérieur a effectivement
adressé une communication aux directeurs
départementaux des services d'incendié
et de secours en novembre 2020 suite à
la réponse de la commission européenne
sur la question cette directive
européenne du temps de travail la dtt et
c'est bien d'un message pour leur
annoncer cette concertation
il existe aujourd'hui vous le savez un
consensus partagé par une très grande
majorité des parties prenantes sur la
nécessité de pouvoir adapter notre
modèle actuel de volontariat non pas
pour remettre en cause son mode de
fonctionnement qui a largement fait ses
preuves vous l'avez très bien rappelé
temps au quotidien que dans les crises
et je voudrais ici saluer le travail de
ces sapeurs pompiers volontaires partout
en france mais bien pour veiller à
encadrer certains points qui pourraient
notamment risqué de conduire à des
décisions de justice qui serait
contraire aux principes de l'engagement
citoyen que nous défendons ici
collectivement c'est donc bien sous le
sceau de la transparence et de la
concertation que le ministère de
l'intérieur a voulu initier ces travaux
qui doivent nous permettre de trouver
des solutions à ces problématiques qui
ont été soulevées par la directive
européenne de 2003 concernant certains
aspects notamment de l'aménagement du
temps de travail
dans cet esprit je voudrais vous dire
que des entretiens avec les associations
d'élus avec les organisations
représentatives des sapeurs pompiers ont
eu lieu et vont continuer de se tenir
la réflexion qui vient de s'engager doit
pouvoir permettre en liaison étroite
évidemment avec les 10 avec l'ensemble
des acteurs et partenaires de disposer
de leurs analyses sur les problématiques
mais aussi leurs propositions je
voudrais vous dire ici au nom du
ministère de l'intérieur que nos
objectifs ils sont clairs maintenir une
son efficace des dix sans perdre de
potentiel opérationnel proposer une
solution concertée et soutenue
évidemment par l'ensemble des acteurs de
la sécurité civile qui ne porterait pas
atteinte à notre modèle de volontariat
tout en sécurisant évidemment ce
dispositif au regard du droit de l'ue
dans cette concertation à venir je
voudrais vous dire que nous n'écartons
pas d'hypothèses notamment pour répondre
plus précisément votre question la
proposition d'une initiative citoyenne
qui pourrait dispenser les sapeurs
fonction volontaire de la déroute était
dans le cadre de la présidence française
de l'union européenne c'est un travail
que nous menons avec le secrétaire
d'état a chargé ces questions vous en
remercie merci madame la ministre
monsieur chat ça il faudrait cinq
secondes
oui donc une fois pour toutes il faut
régler le problème généré par cette
directive européenne qui depuis dix
mille 2003 hypothèque l'avenir des
sapeurs pompiers volontaires volontaire
ban est régulièrement indispensable au
milieu rural et à la france merci
monsieur c'est simple la parole et à
monsieur jean françois husson pour le
groupe l'est républicain
madame la présidente madame la mise la
cohésion des territoires comme moi vous
entendez les préoccupations et les
inquiétudes grandissantes des
collectivités locales plus partir dans
des communes et des intercommunalités
fortement mobilisés mais aussi des
départements sur la dégradation de leur
situation financière
pour mieux répondre à l'urgence de la
crise sanitaire et à ses conséquences
même si les chiffres ne sont pas
totalement stabilisée
l'association des maires de france
estime autour de 5 milliards d'euros les
pertes pour les communes imputable à la
crise sanitaire et 25% des
intercommunalités juge aujourd'hui leur
situation financière dégradée les
collectivités concernées demandent et
méritent toute notre attention
madame la ministre devant
l'hétérogénéité des situations dans nos
territoires qu un plan d'action le
gouvernement entend t-il mettre en
oeuvre pour soutenir les collectivités
et leur permettre de préparer la sortie
de crise et préserver leurs
investissements locaux suçons gouro
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le rapporteur général jean
françois husson
comme vous le savez le gouvernement a
pris de nombreuses mesures de soutien
aux collectivités territoriales dont les
finances ont été effectivement très
touché par la crise que nous traversons
j'en cite quelques unes bien sûr le
filet de sécurité pour les communes qui
je rappelle a été revotée dans la loi de
finances pour 2021
vous avez parlé des départements vous
vous rappelez d avance aussi pour les dm
théo
je rappelle aussi bien sûr la
possibilité d'étaler sur cinq ans les
coûts liés à la crise qui est me semble
important également
et puis nous n'avons pas relâché et au
contraire nous avons développé les
soutien à l'investissement massif pour
les collectivités territoriales grâce au
plan
relance au total c'est à peu près 7
milliards d'euros qui a été consacrée
aux collectivités territoriales alors
bien sûr en partie grâce à ces mesures
en partie je dis bien on peut constater
que les finances locales ont mieux
résisté qu'on ne l'imaginé
les remontées nationale à fin janvier
indiquent une baisse de 1,4 pour cent
des recettes de fonctionnement et une
hausse de 0 2% des dépenses de
fonctionnement
je dis bien toutes collectivités
territoriales confondues ainsi même s'il
épargne brute diminue puisque l'épargné
brute diminue de 3,7 milliards d'euros
elle se maintient au même niveau qu'en
2018 est bien au dessus des niveaux bien
sûr des années précédentes
cette tendance souligne que les budgets
locaux sont je dirais résistant même si
nous savons qu'il y a des grandes
inégalités bien sûr selon les
collectivités territoriales je dirais
elles sont d'autant plus résiliente
comme on dit aujourd'hui si on la
compare à la baisse du pib de vie de 8,4
pour cent en 2020
donc nous sommes conscients que la crise
ne touche pas toutes les collectivités
de la même manière et c'est pourquoi
avec olivier l'usoc nous avons engagé un
travail de fond avec les associations
d'élus du bloc communal pour affiner ces
constats généraux et apprécier l'impact
collectivités hilmar évolutivité faut
que ce travail est en cours et bien sûr
on vous y associera merci monsieur son
vous avez la parole pour une minute
oui pardon madame la ministre merci pour
les éclaircissements que vous apportez
mais ils sont malheureusement pour
l'instant insuffisant je veux quand même
rappeler que dans les communes par
exemple de plus de 3500 habitants et
dans les grandes villes
nous avons eu des baisses tarifaires
très importante de plus de 30 %
concernant les recettes tarifaires et de
plus de 20 % concernant l'occupation du
domaine public
je rappelle d'ailleurs que dans ces
villes et dans ces grands centres
urbains se trouve
le taux le plus important de pauvreté et
de précarité c'est nomen bien sûr et
malheureusement aggravée par la crise du
coc vide
19 je vais dire aussi et vous l'avez dit
que le choc est pour le moins
asymétrique et qu'ils touchent des
territoires avec des forces différentes
comme les communes thermales touristique
où les situés en zone de montagne qui se
sont vus privés de leurs principales
recettes financières par exemple avec la
fermeture de tous les établissements
touristiques
enfin madame la ministre je le dis ne
répétait pas le couac des masques
souvenez vous qu'à l'époque il était
inutile mais aujourd'hui les communes
attendent encore trop souvent d'être
remboursé de la part que l'état leur
avait promise donc soyez au rendez vous
merci merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur r
gillet pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues plus de 7%
de rsa 230 mille chômeurs de plus et
cela l'opportunité pour une relance de
la réforme de l'assurance chômage s'est
ain à chronique et provoquant vous
annoncez votre réforme pour l'été 2021
en pleine tempête économique alors que
le recours au chômage est plus que
jamais un instrument d'équilibré et de
justice
malgré les incertitudes votre
gouvernement parie sur une hypothétique
reprise et s'attaque à l'un des outils
les plus essentiels de notre solidarité
dès que la clause de retour à meilleure
fortune sera engagée l'unedic prévoit
que votre réforme imposera à plus de 850
mille personnes quatre chômeurs sur dix
une baisse moyenne de 22 % de leur
indemnisation
il faudra désormais avoir travaillé six
mois sur 24 au lieu de quatre mois sur
28 pour accéder à une allocation alors
que tant de nos entreprises surtout les
plus petites sont en difficulté et peine
à maintenir leurs emplois
c'est sûr les plus fragiles et précaires
que vous fait peser vos objectifs
d'économies en diminuant leurs droits en
estimant qu'ils font le choix du chômage
c'est faux ils le subissent les plus
impactés touche en moyenne 1300 euros s
sur eux qu'il faut réaliser vos
économies les français sont inquiets
la pauvreté s'accroît de manière
dramatique depuis l'arrivée de l'aco
vide malgré la solidarité nationale
alors qu'il faudrait créer les
conditions de la confiance vous ajouter
à l'inquiétude profonde de la population
des sentiments d'injustice d'incertitude
et de détresse
tous les partenaires sociaux sont contre
et nous sommes nombreux à vous demander
d'abroger ce projet de réforme conçue en
dans un tout autre contexte et inadaptés
en temps de crise de l'aveu même de
l'ancien directeur de cabinet de muriel
pénicaud
allez vous poursuivre malgré ces alertes
au risque d'une véritable casse sociale
chers collègues la parole est à madame
elisabeth bord ministre du travail de
l'emploi et de l'insertion
madame la ministre merci madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur gilet en
vous écoutant je me pose la question de
quelle réforme parlez vous la réforme
que j'ai présenté hier aux partenaires
sociaux est le fruit de six mois des
changes ininterrompue au cours duquel
j'ai écouté les observations les
propositions des uns et des autres et
cette réforme
elle repose sur deux principes lutter
contre la précarité et assurer plus
d'équité dans le calcul des allocations
chômage la réforme met en place un
système de bonus malus qui encourage les
entreprises vertueuses en terme d'emploi
et qui dissuade les entreprises qui
recourent excessivement aux contrats
courts je pense que nous pourrions nous
retrouver sur cette mesure et
contrairement à ce que j'entends dire
parfois la réforme ne réduit pas les
droits des allocataires
le montant total le montant total des
allocations est strictement conserver ce
qui veut dire que si la location
mensuelle baisse un mois donné lé
service sur plus longtemps et par
ailleurs la concertation nous a conduits
à mettre en place un plancher pour
éviter des allocations trop basse je
rappelle également que depuis le début
de la crise nous agissons massivement
contre la précarité avec l'activité
partielle en prolongeant quand c'est
nécessaire
les droits des demandeurs d'emploi en
mettant en place une aide exceptionnelle
pour l'état travailleurs les plus
précaires 460000 ont pu en bénéficier
donc la lutte contre la précarité est et
restera au coeur de l'action de ce
gouvernement
merci madame la ministre
monsieur gilles et vous avez 21 une
seconde pour la réplique
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre nous le savons votre volonté
avec le gouvernement et d'afficher une
capacité de réforme
après l'enterrement de celle des
retraites la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
elle n'est pas politique elle est
politicienne elle est anachronique et
inadapté
merci sa collègue la parole et à
monsieur philippe dominati pour le
groupe est républicain
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente va question
s'adresse à monsieur bruno le maire
ministre de l'économie des finances car
il y a deux mois en 2020 londres était
la principale place financière d'europe
la moitié des transactions du marché des
actions vont migrer vers l'union
européenne
et contre toute attente après quatre
siècles amsterdam est devenue la
première place financière européenne
devant londres et paris maintient tout à
fait sa troisième place avec une légère
progression
mais loin derrière avec deux tiers à peu
près des transactions de la bourse de
londres
il est vrai que les gouvernements
français ont fait pendant longtemps la
promotion de la fiscalité hollandaise en
plaçant les participations de l'état
seront la place aux landaises à la et il
est vrai aussi que ça montre l exemple à
des groupes nationaux tels que le groupe
vivendi qui annonce la capitalisation de
sa filiale d'universal à la haye dans
quelques mois et donc la question est à
peu près simple bruno le maire avait
déclaré en février 2018 que l'objectif
du gouvernement était de faire de paris
la principale place financière d'europe
d'europe continentale affirmation qui
avait été confirmée par le premier
ministre devant les élus franciliens
manifestement c'est loupé alors ma
question est simple pour le gouvernement
comment se fait-il que le gouvernement
et hollandais a été plus performant que
les autorités françaises pour capter
l'essentiel de ces transactions
financières et deuxièmement à bercy qui
s'occupe de la place de paris
si chers collègues la parole est à
madame olivia grégoire secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'économie sociale solidaire
et responsable
monsieur le sénateur dominati vous poser
une question relative à l'attractivité
de la place et la bourse de paris c'est
effectivement un sujet essentiel sur
lequel le gouvernement est mobilisé
depuis 2010 est est pas trop tard la
france conduit un vaste programme de
réformes visant à renforcer la place des
services financiers en tant que vecteur
de croissance dans notre pays
nous sommes à l'avant-garde en matière
d'innovation dans le domaine des
services financiers dans le domaine que
j'ai le plaisir de traiter pour bruno le
maire la finance verte la finance
durable le sujet d'aujourd'hui mais
surtout peut-être qui nous intéresse de
demain ainsi que pour les applications
relatives à la blocs shine vous l'avez
dit monsieur le sénateur depuis 2019
paris a cherché à attirer a réussi à
attirer des acteurs financiers
internationaux je pense à la
relocalisation des plateformes de
négociation de goldman sachs et d'axis
je pense aussi à l'ouverture du nouveau
bureau de la citadelle la création des
filiales européennes de chubb et de bank
of america qui sont autant d'exemples
qui illustrent est concrètement
l'attractivité croissante de la place
paris est ainsi le seul centre financier
continental avoir réussi à capter
l'ensemble de l'écosystème services
financiers vous le savez pour terminer
monsieur le sénateur depuis le 1er
janvier 2021 et à la fin de la période
de transition du break site
les actions entreprises d'entreprise de
l'union échangés en euros ne peuvent
plus être échangé sur les plateformes
boursières du royaume uni à qui la
commission européenne a fait le choix de
ne pas octroyer d'équivalence ce
mouvement important de rapatriement des
échanges d'actions dans lieux a conduit
à la relocalisation dans lieux des
principales plates formes
internationales des changes d'actions
paris au côté d'amsterdam que vous
mentionniez on a été l'un des deux
principaux bénéficiaires en attirant
cette plateforme anglo saxonnes dont par
exemple celles de goldman sachs en
matière d'introduction en bourse pour
terminer de nouvelles entreprises paris
bénéficie aussi son attractivité
renouvelé ainsi paris devrait être dans
l'europe post break shit l'une des deux
place principale de cotation de l'union
européenne avec francfort
nous avions pris ce pari et nous sommes
proches du résultat merci pour votre
question merci madame la ministre
monsieur dominati vous avez 26 secondes
pour la réplique
madame la ministre d'autant que vous
êtes une ministre et lui à paris votre
réponse est préoccupante parce que tous
les acteurs économiques ont compris que
les arguments que vous développez sont
les mêmes que ceux de me bruno le maire
en 2018
il serait temps de réagir vous comprenez
bien que je vous demandais quel était
votre réactivité après ce premier échec
vous me reprenait les arguments de 2018
nous attendions autre chose je sais que
ce gouvernement s'intéresse pas de l'as
s'intéresse pas à la région parisienne
au grand paris c'est le premier
gouvernement sous la vème république
n'est très touchée mal la région
capitale
merci la volonté mais jeune françoise
férat pour le groupe union centriste
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adressait à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture en
2018 la ferme france à conserver son
statut de première puissance agricole
européenne avec une production estimée à
73 milliards d'euros et une contribution
au pib de 6 7%
ces chiffres démontrent la compétitivité
et la performance de l'agriculture
française la meilleure du monde en
termes qualitatifs nutritionnelle et
environnementaux en des temps normaux
nous devrions rencontrer à cette période
de l'année
les agriculteurs de nos territoires au
salon de l'agriculture à la porte de
versailles
à défaut cette année sont proposés des
journées sur tout le territoire
mais les années suivantes ne
ressembleront pas à 2021 et ce serait de
bonne augure
c'est pourquoi avec mes collègues du
groupe union centriste
nous demandons simplement et
symboliquement la création d'une journée
nationale de l'agriculture une date en
juin semble convenir si j'en crois les
demandes qui m'ont été faites
monsieur le ministre évidemment cette
demande et je me permets d'insister ne
doit pas masquer les critiques dirigées
contre la mauvaise application de la loi
et galim où les dégâts de la grippe
aviaire pour n'en citer que
quelques-unes mais bien au contraire
valoriser les métiers d'agriculture
cette journée permettra aux acteurs de
la filière de mettre en valeur la
spécificité des territoires et les
nouvelles techniques plus durable elle
doit permettre aux concitoyens de
connaître les femmes et les hommes
passionnés qui nourrissent la population
il s'agira d'un geste fort qui sortira
le secteur agricole de son sentiment de
découragement et marquera la
considération que l'ensemble du pays
doit apporter à nos paysans et je compte
sur monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture pour répondre
favorablement cette demande
merci chalet
le favori ça monsieur gabriela tall
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre porte parole du gouvernement
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice fait rage au prix d'abord
d'excuser l'absence de mon collègue
ministre de l'agriculture et
l'alimentation julien de normandie qui
est retenu au à l'assemblée nationale
pour une audition et qui aurait
évidemment aimé vous répondre puisque
nous devrions en ce moment être en train
de vivre un très grand moment pour notre
pays qui est chaque année le salon de
l'agriculture est le salon de
l'agriculture il nous manque
il manque évidemment aux élus
responsables politiques aux agriculteurs
mais il manque à tous les français parce
que c'est un moment qui permet de
rappeler notre attachement notre soutien
à la filière agricole dans notre pays et
nous aimerions pouvoir le faire d'autant
plus cette année que depuis un an si
nous avons traversé cette crise et si
les français ont pu traverser cette
crise et les confinements avec toujours
de quoi se nourrir c'est parce que nous
avons des agriculteurs qui ne comptent
pas leurs heures qui ne comptent pas
leur mobilisation et qui sont mobilisés
pour permettre de nourrir les français
et donc oui il faut les soutenir
nous les soutenons depuis 2010 est avec
notamment la loi et galim les circuits
courts ou le plan de relance qui prévoit
1,2 milliard d'euros pour l'agriculture
ou encore aux négociations que nous
avons avec bruxelles qui permettent
maintenant que 99% des aides de la pac
soit versée dans les temps mais vous
avez raison il faut aussi faire
connaître nos agriculteurs leur métier
pour cela mon collègue de l'agriculture
m'indique plusieurs éléments qui je
crois répondront à votre suggestions et
propositions
d'abord le centre national des concours
et expositions agricoles organisera au
printemps la semaine française de
l'agriculture avec des échanges et des
conférences ensuite les journées
nationales de l'agriculture se
dérouleront en jean elles permettront
aux français comme vous le souhaitez de
visiter des exploitations et de saisir
la réalité du métier d'agriculteur
enfin évidemment pour que chacune et
chacun dans nos interventions et c'était
encore le cas la semaine dernière où je
viens de normandie était là pour
répondre nous pouvons en permanence
rappelé le rôle et la place absolument
indispensable est essentiel de nos
agriculteurs dans notre pays et je vous
remercie au nom du gouvernement de
l'avoir fait à nouveau
merci monsieur le ministre madame ferrat
ivresse 4 secondes donc c'est vraiment
deux mots si vous souhaitez profiter de
la réplique oui monsieur le ministre je
ne suis pas certaine d'avoir bien
compris vous parlez de journée de
l'agriculture
moi je vous parle d'une journée
nationale de l'agriculture si madame la
farol et ça madame frédérique puissat
pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la fin merci à la présidente à
mataro ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'emploi madame la ministre
vous avez fait le choix de poursuivre
les discussions avec les partenaires
sociaux sur la réforme de l'assurance
chômage et nous ne pouvons que vous en
féliciter
la question de la temporalité et des
réformes successives sur ce dossier en
est une autre et la crise économique ne
gomme pas dans le contexte le contexte
dans lequel nous nous trouvons un
contexte de d'abord de gouvernance
complexe avec les partenaires sociaux
qui a été rappelé par mes collègues non
pas par leur fai mais bien par les
négociations désastreuse du gouvernement
dr philippe sur ce sujet un contest qui
par vos réformes quand un rang le
service public de l'emploi plus
dépendants de la conjoncture économique
ce qui ne dessine des perspectives
financières pour pôle emploi en 2022
extrêmement incertaines
un contexte où nous vous tendons la main
en proposant que le document de cadrage
adressé aux partenaires sociaux sur ce
sujet fasse l'objet d'une discussion au
parlement ce qui a été balayé d'un
revers de manche par le gouvernement
précédent
un contexte incertain sur l'état du réel
du marché et ccc et certains secteurs
mais question sont donc au nombre de
trois pensez vous que les discussions
d'hier vont rhône d'hier vont renouer
les liens et faciliter le dialogue entre
les partenaires sociaux sur la réforme
de l'assurance chômage
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faille pour
cette réforme accepté de travailler
davantage avec le parlement les régions
et les départements
avant la sortie d'un décret qui gravera
dans le marbre les futures règles
d'indemnisation des années à venir
enfin ne faut-il pas au regard de la
conjoncture envisager des solutions à
géométrie variable selon les branches ou
les secteurs géographiques qui seront
sans doute impacté de façon différenciée
les uns des autres
merci
la parole est à madame elisabeth bord
ministre du travail de l'emploi et de
l'insertion
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice frédérique puissat comme vous
je suis attachée au dialogue social et
je suis convaincu que les partenaires
sociaux jouent un rôle essentiel depuis
le début de la crise c'est bien pour
cela qu'au cours des six derniers mois
j'ai écouté les propositions les
observations des uns et des autres et
c'est comme ça que nous avons construit
la réforme que j'ai pu présenter hier
par exemple en réponse aux observations
des organisations syndicales
nous avons fait le choix de décaler au
1er juillet la mise en oeuvre de cette
réforme
à un moment où notre stratégie vaccinale
sera pleinement montée en puissance avec
des impacts positifs en termes
économiques et sociales et puis nous
avons aussi fait le choix de maintenir
l'ouverture des droits au bout de quatre
mois comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
tant que la situation du marché du
travail n'est pas revenue à la normale
et je pense que c'est une avancée
importante que nous avons introduites
avec ses clause de retour à meilleure
fortune qui répond à une considération
de bon sens que les paramètres de
l'assurance chômage doivent pouvoir
s'adapter en tenant compte de la
situation du marché du travail
et puis comme vous avez vu nous avons
également instauré un plancher pour
éviter les allocations trop basse comme
les organisations syndicales nous le
demander et puis pour répondre aussi aux
inquiétudes des organisations patronales
nous avons aménagé le dispositif de me
bonus malus pour que les périodes on va
dire atypique de l'année 2020 et du
début de l'année 2021 ne rentrent pas en
grand compte dans le calcul de ce bonus
malus et que les secteurs qui sont le
plus affectés par la crise ne soient pas
concernés
donc c'est vraiment une écoute
permanente des organisations patronales
et syndicales qui nous a permis
d'élaborer la réforme qui était présenté
hier est par ailleurs nous devons ouvrir
avec les partenaires sociaux une
discussion sur la gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage qui doit nous perdre
qui doit permettre à chacun l'état
partenaires sociaux le parton le
parlement de trouver toute leur place
dans cette gouvernance de l'assurance
chômage soit merci merci madame la
ministre madame puis cela vous avez la
parole pour prendre cette seconde où
madame la présidente je ne sais pas si
vous êtes une femme de gauche madame la
ministre comme le dit madame cécile
cukierman en tout état de cause nous
sommes nombreux à considérer que les
conditions d'un dialogue serein avec les
partenaires sociaux n'ont pas été au
rendez vous ils ne l'ont pas été avec le
gouvernement d'edouard philippe en ce
qui vous concerne c' est vrai que vous
avez cherché à revoir la copie mais sur
la forme elle n'était pas la bonne d'un
ami je crois que très certainement les
territoires ne peuvent pas satisfaire
d'une réforme qui va les impacts et les
départements les régions n'ont pas été
associés à cette réforme
le parlement l'a pas été les partenaires
sociaux un sentiment de rené faute d'une
réforme excessivement verticale bref le
rendez vous social n'est pas au rendez
vous comme on peut le dire mais par
contre peut-être que le calendrier était
peut-être plutôt celui de l'élection
présidentielle
thierry cosy pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et république
merci la présidente va question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie
toutes les guerres ont leurs trésors
paraît-il 200 milliards c'est le montant
du surcroît d'epargne qui sera cumulé à
la fin de l'année dans notre pays soit
près de 8% du pib
cette épargne inhabituel réinjectés dans
l'économie pourrait permettre de
compenser les effets de la pandémie et
assurer un vrai rebond de l'activité
ces sommes porte en elle toute
l'iniquité de cette crise c'est sans
surprise que 70% du surcroît de
l'epargne et réalisé par les 20% des
ménages les plus riches en france
l'argent n'est pas fait pour être
entassés
il est fait pour circuler aux
tergiversations sur la question coûte
cher à la france en matière de
libéralisation d'epargne la confiance et
cardinal
en ce sens les atermoiements sur la
politique vaccinale ne sont
malheureusement pas de nature à ramener
cette confiance dont nous avons tant
besoin
je n'appelle pas à toucher à l'épargné
de précaution accumulés par le
concitoyens les plus modestes mais je
vous demande de mettre à contribution
ceux pour qui la crise a permis cette
accumulation rétablir lisf pour
contribuer à l'effort de solidarité
c'est non taxer l'épargné plus aisé pour
relancer l'économie
encore non en refusant cela vous acté
vote renoncement à faire contribuer ceux
pour qui la crise a été synonyme
d'enrichissement une mobilisation par
l'impôt permettrait une répartition plus
égalitaire de l'effort de relance
monsieur le ministre le virus se propage
sur un terrain qui est déjà miné par les
inégalités c'est là dessus celles ci
n'ont eu de cesse de se creuser dans des
proportions inédites
comment comptez vous mobiliser ce fond
de guerre
théorisée par les citoyens les plus
aisés alors qu'un embryon de justice
fiscale puisse enfin voir le jour dans
votre quinquennat il vous reste encore
un an
rien n'est jamais trop tard
si chaque collègue la parole et à madame
olivia grégoire secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'économie sociale solidaire
et responsable
monsieur le sénateur cozic vous
m'interrogez sur le fléchage de
l'epargne dans la relance de l'économie
sujet sur lequel le gouvernement est
mobilisé depuis 2010 est et depuis 2010
8 vous vous en rappelez je n'en doute
pas nous avions avec laurent saint
martin avec amélie de montchalin lorsque
nous étions au parlement lancé les
rendez-vous de l'investissement
productif je ne doute pas que vous aviez
suivi ça de très près vous avez rappelé
qu' aujourd'hui en 2020 c'est à peu près
de 101 milliards d'euros d'épargné qui
sont disponibles vous parlez de trésors
c'est le trésor c'est surtout l'argent
des français et notre objectif est clair
que c'était par une servent au
financement de l'économie réelle de nos
entreprises c'est dans l'intérêt des
épargnants
ça leur apporte de la rentabilité dans
un contexte de taux bas vous le savez
c'est aussi voire surtout aussi dans
l'intérêt de nos entreprises qui ont
toujours besoin de ces ressources pour
investir consolider leurs fonds propres
et repartir cet objectif est un objectif
poursuivi maintenant depuis quatre ans
nous avons intensifié cette action avec
la relance
le label relance que nous avons lancée
en octobre 2020 permet aux épargnants
d'identifier les fonds qui cible tout
particulièrement les investissements en
fonds propres et quasi fonds propres
dans les entreprises françaises et
notamment dans les pme et les
entreprises de taille intermédiaire
c'est un vrai succès avec près de 150
fonds labellisés aujourd'hui 25
milliards d'encours cible qui sera
investi à 70% dans les entreprises
françaises 60% de ces fonds sont
accessibles aux épargnants particuliers
qui souhaitent donner du sens à leur
épargne et vous le savez ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux
enfin nous avons mise en oeuvre des
mécanismes pour flécher les parcs vers
des entreprises à un pacte et nous
incitons de plus en plus chacun des
français à mettre leurs trésors leur
épargne au service du développement de
cette économie
davigny
je vous remercie monsieur le sénateur
cogic merci madame la ministre monsieur
cosy qui vous restent six secondes vous
ne souhaitez pas en bénéficier la parole
est à monsieur pardon il vous reste six
secondes
je vais faire très vite madame la
ministre les bas de laine et les matelas
de certains nos concitoyens sont
remplies de grâce épargnez nouveau
dispositif incantatoire qui ne touche
qu'une infime partie nos concitoyens
libéré équitablement l'epargne dans
notre économie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur jean raymond hugonnet pour le
groupe l'est républicain
merci madame la présidente il ya des
connaisseurs ici ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
lille est belle et toumani 14 ans sont
morts dans l'essonne lundi et mardi
derniers respectivement à saint chéron
et boussy-saint-antoine deux charmantes
et paisible bourgade à la suite
d'affrontements entre jeunes
c'est l'horreur absolue rien de bien
nouveau me direz vous puisque l'amnésie
collective ou le parfum de bonne
conscience nous font passer sous silence
le meurtre du jeune romuald par exemple
14 ans lui aussi lâchement abattu en
pleine rue à courcouronnes le 8 novembre
2000 victimes gratuite d'une vieille
histoire d'impayés entre deux familles
sur fond de rivalités entre quartiers
alors notre pays regorge de sociologues
éminemment compétents nous croulons sous
les analyses pertinentes et détaillée du
phénomène de violence en bandes gang ou
autres tribus bien sûr le sujet est
extrêmement complexe
bien sûr la prévention bien sur
l'accompagnement mais quand allez vous
répondre enfin monsieur le ministre à
l'appel de détresse des élus de
l'essonne
obligé par exemple de quémander les
crédits de leurs plans de prévention
spécialisée
quand allez vous enfin donner les moyens
aux communes de recomposer des quartiers
à vivre plutôt que de les matraquer
aveuglément avec l'article 55 de la loi
sru
quand allez vous claquez qualité enfin
l'évolution des effectifs de police et
de gendarmerie sur la croissance
démographique exponentielle d'un
département comme le nôtre alors que
nous le demandons en vain depuis des
années en atteste le 26 janvier 1989 la
demande du sénateur communiste robert
visait auquel je veux rendre hommage ici
qui attirait déjà l'attention de votre
homologue de l'époque monsieur le
ministre
comme je le fais aujourd'hui sur
l'insuffisance des effectifs de police
et de gendarmerie dans le département de
l'essonne
c'est at il ya 32 ans
chers collègues la parole est à mme à la
marlène schiappa ministre délégué chargé
de la citoyenneté
merci à madame la présidente
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur jean
raymond hugonnet je représente le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
que vous interrogez vous dressez
d'ailleurs un constat important sur la
question à des violences et notamment
des violences en bandes dans l'essonne
et je vais vous dire que ce constat de
violence inacceptables nous le
partageons évidemment le gouvernement
est à pied d'oeuvre pour y répondre vous
évoquez certains faits de jeu lens en
essonne moi je voudrais rappeler ici que
dans l'année écoulée ce sont 91
événement en essonne qui ont eu lieu de
cet ordre lié à des questions de
violence et à des bandes alors tous
n'ont pas d'écho médiatique comme comme
certains faits j'adresse évidemment mes
pensées à la famille de ses victimes
mais aucun pour autant on est acceptable
d'ailleurs on observe que les
belligérants sont de plus en plus jeunes
année après année et que là nous avons
maintenant à faire à des jeunes entre
eux en moyenne 13 et 17 ans qui cause
parfois des blessures très graves et
d'effets irréversibles
alors il arrive souvent que ces drames
soient évités de peu grâce à
l'intervention des forces de sécurité
intérieure qui font que vous avez raison
de le rappeler un fail difficile
notamment dans certains quartiers je
voudrais ici les en remercier face à ce
constat le gouvernement agit nous avons
mis en oeuvre de façon opérationnelle un
certain nombre de dispositifs et moi je
ne voudrais pas monsieur sénateur opposé
la prévention et la répression ou la
prévention à l'action notre action elle
est liée de manière indissociable de
prévention et de répression d'abord il
ya effectivement une action répressive
et judiciaire grâce à un travail de
coopération qui est instants avec le
parquet d'evry comme vous le savez au
sein de la cellule de lutte contre les
trafics et du référent de lutte contre
les bandes qui a été nommé sous son
autorité dans chaque circonscription de
sécurité grâce à cela les procédures
judiciaires pour participation à un
attroupement armé ont par exemple été
initiés comme le recours à
l'exploitation vidéo qui a été
systématisé par ailleurs la mise en
place de dispositifs dite d' alerte
précoce pour assurer une intervention
rapide des forces de sécurité intérieure
elle a été déployée est d'ores et déjà
elle a donné des résultats probants
notamment sur le secteur de corbeil
essonnes où vous le savez certains
affrontements ont très récemment pu être
évité grâce à des interpellations
préventive d'acteurs qui s'apprêtait à
en découdre si on peut dire de cette
manière par ailleurs la question de la
logique de prévention
elle est évidemment renforcée en amont
avec les acteurs locaux les ebooks lui
on n'a jamais nazisme en scolaire en ce
sens je voudrais vous dire que en lien
avec le garde des sceaux
le ministre de l'éducation nationale est
sous l'autorité du vice un travail a été
lancé pour ennuis la présente en mai
2021 le nouveau plan de lutte contre les
bandes sera donc annoncé l'un d'eux me
faire des ministres la parole est à
monsieur ghosn et vous avez 12 secondes
encore un plan madame la ministre encore
des confettis de parole
nous ne nous payons plus de mots nous
voulons des actes et des personnels
supplémentaires en essonne que nous
demandons depuis 32 ans
merci réveillez vous merci chers
collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean françois
longeot pour le groupe union centriste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre
à mesure que la crise sanitaire dur elle
soulève chaque jour son lot de questions
mais une question essentielle se pose
comment rattraper notre cap vaccinale
car alors que la campagne de vaccination
cherche à s'accélère en france
je tiens vous interroger sur l'île aux
fantômes dont notre pays semble se
priver en effet selon de nombreux
professionnels de santé alors que seuls
10 doses sont initialement prévu dans
les flacons des vaccins moderna il
serait possible d'en tirer une onzième
très facilement il allait il en allait
d'ailleurs de même pour le fai vaccin
misère pour lequel seuls cinq doses
était initialement prévu tandis qu'une
sixième était finalement autorisé ainsi
sous réserve de précaution
il serait donc possible de vacciner
plus de personnes avec la même quantité
de vaccins dans une commune de 4000
habitants et j'ai pu faire le tour de
certaines communes pour voir un peu
comment ça se passait sur les
vaccinations de mon département
cela représente environ 3 doses par jour
soit 15 par semaine
après les tensions à privas privés
d'approvisionnement pardon on imagine
aisément le gaspillage que cela
représente à l'échelle nationale et le
potentiel non utilisés au profit de
cette stratégie de vaccination
monsieur le ministre les autorités
médicales évoluent encadré risque
parfois des poursuites si elle utilise
cette onzième doses quelles réponses
pouvez vous leur apportez face à ce
paradoxe insupportable pourquoi ne pas
utiliser ces doses supplémentaires pour
des patients ayant déjà été infectées
par le virus et pour lesquels la haute
autorité de santé recommande
l'utilisation d'une seule dose
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame brigitte
bourguignon ministre délégué chargé de
l'autonomie merci et madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président jean
françois longeot merci de votre question
qui me permet de rappeler le souci
constant je pense que nous le partageons
du gouvernement d'accélérer notre
stratégie vaccinale est de permettre à
nos concitoyens de se prémunir au mieux
du virus notamment dans ses formes
aggravante ce sont plus de 3 millions
personnes qui ont reçu une première
injection et 1,7 million qui vont avoir
le deuxième au 2 mars
avec déjà une satisfaction notamment
auprès des personnes les plus âgées les
plus vulnérables avec la ministre agnès
panière une hache et nous avons le souci
permanent de l'accessibilité des doses
leurs importations leur production avec
clément bonne nous oeuvrons à la
meilleure coordination européenne
possible pour être plus forts ensemble
en ce qui concerne l' usage de ces doses
nous veillons avec olivier ferrand est
ce que celle ci aille au public bien sûr
en priorité en raison de leur
vulnérabilité de leur co morbidité et je
me félicite que près de 80 % +2 81% nos
concitoyens en ehpad ont pu bénéficier
de cette première dose je voulais vous
dire aussi que nos aînés sont désormais
moins fragilisés et donc ont moins
recours aux services d'urgences et
c'était le but est la stratégie
poursuivie comme vous le voyez nous
partageons avec vous monsieur le
sénateur cet objectif de disposer de
doses suffisantes qui soit pleinement
efficiente efficaces et qu'ils puissent
être administré dans les meilleurs
délais c'est à cette fin que
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché du
vaccin moderna prévoit que chaque flacon
contient dix doses néanmoins afin de
s'assurer dans les meilleurs délais qui
nous soit possible d'exploiter
éventuellement une onzième dose et par
anticipation
l'état a mis à disposition des
établissements de santé des centres de
vaccination du matériel adapté de
requêtes pour adapter à la récupération
de la 11ème doses il s'agit de seringue
particulière nous anticipons donc cet
enjeu qui est primordial pour organiser
ces doses dont nous disposons et d'en
faire bénéficier bien sûr le plus grand
nombre dans les meilleurs délais je
remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur longeau pour 8 secondes
oui mais merci madame à miss merci pour
votre réponse mais c'est vraiment
important parce que quand il ya on peut
mettre 11 dose pas disent c'est quand
même important de pouvoir permettre
effectivement d'utiliser l'ensemble des
flacons bercy merci chers collègues je
vous rappelle que les prochaines
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
auront lieu mercredi 10 mars à 15 heures
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h30 pour le débat sur
l'accord de commerce et de coopération
entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne
la séance est suspendue
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement de très
nombreux thèmes ont été abordés
vaccination confinement territorialisée
mais aussi assurance chômage ou encore
procès de nicolas sarkozy et tout de
suite on va commencer les réactions
salle des conférences et on va rejoindre
alexandre poussard pour l'interview de
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
et l'air ici au sénat et witam puisque
dans 15 minutes et bien le sénat va
auditionner le gouvernement sur le
projet loi de lutte contre le
séparatisme
bruno retailleau quel va être le mot
d'ordre de la droite sénatoriale pour
modifier ce texte faire que ce texte
soit un texte utile parce que on l'a
bien vu avec les attentats notamment
celui de sa mère pattie il ya la charia
qui commence à s'appliquer sur le
territoire de france la réalité elle est
là et donc ce texte doit être un vrai
instrument une arme pour lutter contre
l'islamisme l'islamisme d'ailleurs qu'il
ne nomme pas ce texte ne sommes pas
islamistes donc dans ce texte nous
ferons en sorte que mon vitamines un
petit peu des propositions qui nous
semble beaucoup trop molle qu'on comble
un certain nombre de manques par exemple
qu'est-ce que le séparatisme par exemple
la question du voile qui est un
instrument un marqueur de séparatisme la
question aussi migratoire sur certains
de ses aspects pour les cartes de séjour
et enfin il faut préserver aussi les
libertés et je pense notamment à la
liberté de l'enseignement
on ne peut pas si aujourd'hui on
notamment de l'enseignement en famille
amoindrir ou même anéantir cette liberté
qui existe depuis 1882 c'est à dire
depuis la grande loi jules ferry vous
parlez du port du voile à l'élu en
sondage ifop qui est paru aujourd'hui
sur le port du voile aux lycéens lycées
an sur deux est favorable au port de
signes religieux au lycée qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce chiffre
je pense que j'ai lu cette étude je
pense que l état c'est dramatique parce
qu'elle révèle de fractures une fracture
entre les générations vous l'avez dit un
sur deux pour les jeunes dont les
lycéens sont favorables
c'est moitié plus que pour leurs aînés
qui eux sont sains car c'est à dire 25 %
ça mérite qu'on s'y attarde et puis il
ya une autre acte sûrs c'est que quand
vous interrogez par exemple les lycéens
pour ça elle pâtit et bientôt les jeunes
compatriotes de profession musulmane dit
que un sur deux il lui donne tort
d'avoir exposé ses caricatures alors que
pour les autres c'est seulement 17% donc
voyez bien que on a cette double comment
dirais-je fracture c'est un échec
c'est l'échec de la transmission de la
laïcité c'est l'échec de la transmission
de nos valeurs de notre histoire aussi
et corse que à force de culpabiliser la
france on rend la france coupable de
tout et donc comment ces jeunes
peuvent-ils m et la france si on désigne
la france toujours coupables on viendra
sans doute sur les a fait revenir
algérie l'instant on rend la france
coupable alors qu'hier soir le président
de la république emmanuel macron au nom
de la france a reconnu l'assassinât par
l'armée française de l'avocat algérien
ali boumendjel pendant la guerre
d'algérie
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de cette
reconnaissance écoutez moi je veux bien
qu'on fasse la clarté la vérité sur
notre histoire il faut pas que ça soit
sens unique
ce que je veux dire c'est que j'attends
aussi l'algérie qu'elle puisse
reconnaître les massacres par exemple
des harkis par dizaines de milliers la
torture aussi sur des français ça doit
être dans les deux sens pour qui et de
l'apaisement
ce que je pense aussi c'est que et c'est
ma crainte c'est que ça ne débouche pas
sur l'apaisement mais c'est plutôt sur
l'attisement d'un ressentiment leurs
sentiments
on le sait vis-à-vis notamment d'un
certain nombre de quartiers deux jeunes
qui sont sur le chemin de la sécession
et qui sont alimentés l'islamisme
s'alimente justement de cette pensée des
colonials du fait que la france
finalement elle incarne le mal dans le
monde et ça l'islamisme s'appuie sur ce
ressentiment pour pouvoir recruter et
puis il ya aussi un autre phénomène
c'est l'algérie vous savez que chaque
vendredi de fear ac a repris puisque les
algériens comtesse leur gouvernement or
le gouvernement depuis des années des
décennies prend prétexte de la
colonisation française pour masquer ses
propres échecs et est de ce point de vue
là ça n'est pas non plus je crois
service à rendre aux algérie donc des
efforts aussi à faire du côté de
l'algérie merci beaucoup à bruno
retailleau d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci merci beaucoup alexandre pour
cette première réaction et je précise un
que le débrief est aujourd'hui écourté
car à 16h30
nous diffuserons en direct l'audition du
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
et de la ministre chargée de la
citoyenneté marlène schiappa autour du
projet de loi comportant le respect des
principes de la république
le texte sur le séparatisme sur lequel
la commission des lois travaillent
depuis plusieurs semaines qui sera
débattu dans l'hémicycle à partir du 30
mars et ensuite vous pourrez également
suivre à 18h30 l'audition du garde des
sceaux
eric dupond-moretti tout de suite on va
rejoindre quand un calme et dans
l'hémicycle du sénat quentin pour un
débrief de ces questions d'actualité je
le disais il ya eu des thématiques
extrêmement variés cet après midi qu est
ce que vous avez retenu tout à fait à me
serais beaucoup beaucoup de sujets très
différents on a parlé agriculture on a
parlé des réformes de l'assurance
chômage on va y revenir on n'a pas de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat mais
parmi les moments forts que l'on a
retenu est bien à cette question
adressée au premier ministre est porté
par la sénatrice ps de paris main et
pierre de la gontrie concernant la
déclaration de gérald darmanin le
ministre l'intérieur qui a soutenu
nicolas sarkozy après sa condamnation
cette semaine et bien c'est gabriel
attal le porte parole ou allemand qui a
répondu rappelant que l'exécutif n'avait
jamais commenter les décisions de
justice depuis le début de ce
quinquennat
une réponse qui n'a pas convaincu main
et pierre de la gontrie écouter à
réplique ce sa réplique elle a trouvé
que le silence de jean castex était
éloquent comment ne pas voir l'effet
dévastateur de l'expression publique
d'un soutien
adressée par le patron des policiers à
une personne lourdement condamnés pour
des manquements à la probité
monsieur le premier ministre nul ne peut
se réjouir de voir un ancien président
de la république condamné pour
corruption mais tous nous devrions nous
réjouir d'avoir une justice qui
s'applique à tous puissants ou
misérables
nous devrions au terme de notre
constitution chérir l'indépendance de
l'autorité judiciaire dans le président
dans le public et le garant il semble
nécessaire aux journées le seul familles
disent que vous le rappeliez à être
communiqués l'intérieur autre sujet qui
a largement mobilisé les groupes
politiques
aujourd'hui lors de cette séance c'est
la réforme de l'assurance chômage on a
entendu trois questions sur le sujet
après la présentation hier par la
ministre isabel bande de cette réforme
devant les partenaires sociaux une
réforme qui fait l'unanimité des
syndicats contre elle notamment sur la
baisse pour 3 pour 830 mille demandeurs
d'emploi de leurs indemnités
eh bien il se demande elle a répondu sur
ce point de la baisse des indemnités et
ça je vous le faire écouter c'était tout
à l'heure contrairement à ce que
j'entends dire parfois la réforme ne
réduit pas les droits des allocataires
le montant total le montant total des
allocations est strictement conserver ce
qui veut dire que si la location
mensuelle baisse un mois donné lé
service sur plus longtemps et par
ailleurs la concertation nous a conduits
à mettre en place un plancher pour
éviter des allocations trop basse voilà
tam pour deux des moments forts
aujourd'hui donc de cette séance avec
une variété de sujets très large
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup quentin pour
toutes ces explications
on va continuer bien à débriefer cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement une séance a également été
marquée par un certain nombre de
questions autour du colis et des
notamment le renforcement des mesures de
restriction qui pourrait atteindre un
certain nombre de départements qui sont
déjà attentivement surveillées
aujourd'hui c'est le cas notamment du
pas de calais le pas-de-calais qui
pourrait aller bien vers un confinement
le week-end pendant trois semaines et à
ce propos alexandre vous êtes avec le
sénateur et l'air du pas de calais jean
françois rapin et oui la situation est
inquiétante dans le département dans le
département du pas de calais
le préfet du département préconise un
confinement le week-end sur trois
semaines jean françois rapin c'est la
bonne solution et on n'a pas le choix
je pense que les mesures qui sont qui
vont être annoncées alors je ne sais pas
elles seront proposées par le préfet au
premier ministre maintenant on verra
quelles seront les annonces du premier
ministre
demain mais en tout cas pour l'instant
on n'a pas le choix parce que le pas de
calais en situation compliquée alors
avec une différence territoriale en
fonction des arrondissements en tout cas
comme je dis toujours ce n'est pas le
virus qui voyagent ce sont les gens et
donc il est important
sans savoir s'il y aura une efficacité
sur ces mesures mais en tout cas de
pouvoir confiné mais le problème n'est
pas là le problème est dans la
vaccination le problème est que depuis
un mois les élus réclament plus de
vaccins dans le pas de calais que nous
avons remarqué depuis des semaines que
nous étions sous dotées et que le taux
de vaccination aujourd'hui dans le pas
de calais est à peu près pour deux
vaccinations parce que je considère que
on a une résistance suffisante à la
maladie dès lors qu'on a deux
vaccination je parle en tant que médecin
est aujourd'hui dans le pas de calais on
est à peu près 1,2 66 % des gens qui
vont se sont vaccinés alors que alors
que en franche comté à dos sacs donc un
vrai paul est justement face à ce
problème est ce que vous demandez une
priorité à donner au pas de calais sur
l'essentiel est essentielle
c'est ce que les élus réclament c'est la
condition sine qua none pour faire
avaler toutes les mesures potentielles
qui vont être prises et qui vont
resserrer la situation mais on ne peut
pas faire autrement ça voudrait dire
déshabiller d'autres départements par
plus de vaccins pas forcément c'est
selon les engagements du gouvernement la
vaccination et les vaccins sont fournis
de plus en plus donc il faut il faut
alimenter logistiquement le pas de
calais de plus en plus et peut-être
créer des centres complémentaires en
tout cas les élus locaux
ils ont annoncé qu'ils étaient prêts
pour pour ouvrir des centres donc ce
sera un moyen d'ouvrir la vaccination à
plus grande échelle
la concertation avec les élus locaux
elle se passe bien pour le moment on a
un préfet qui était vraiment au top je
dirais sur le cheval sur la proximité
sur l'explication et lui fait avec les
moyens qu'on lui donne ok merci beaucoup
jean françois rapin d'avoir répondu à ma
question
merci merci beaucoup à alexandra jean
françois rapin plutôt dans une position
non constructive un vis-à-vis des
restrictions qui pourrait attendre son
département et tout de suite on va
rejoindre jean jaurès notre streamer
politique et anime sénat stream en
parallèle sur la plateforme twitch avec
les internautes et jambes qu'est ce
qu'ils ont retenu de cette séance cet
après midi avec on l'a dit nous en tout
cas on a trouvé qu'avec beaucoup de
thématiques assez varié lui très très
variés mais je n'ai trouvé que vous avez
des sifi du gouvernement et de son expo
on a vu par exemple socialiste qui a
encaissé texte suite aux deux envers
nicolas sarkozy pour corruption
les internautes dans le scénar connaître
comme pierre de la gontrie va pas dans
le sens dans la liste je suis
vu sur l'assurance suis désolé genre
malheureusement franchement en tentant
trop mal cette semaine je suis obligé de
te couper aujourd'hui montrent
retrouvera la semaine prochaine j'espère
dans de meilleures conditions techniques
car il y avait un sujet qui intéressait
beaucoup les internautes c'était la
question de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat tu nous l'avait dit jean et
tout à l'heure et bien au micro
d'alexandre poussard on a eu et bien le
ministre des transports jean baptiste
djebbari interrogé à ce sujet on écoute
oui jean baptiste djebbari le sénateur
écologiste ronan dantec vous a interrogé
sur les objectifs internationaux de la
france en matière de lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
alors on le rappelle le projet de loi
climat attirer des travaux de la
convention citoyenne est basé sur un
objectif de réduction de -40% des gaz à
effet de serre mais les objectifs
internationaux ont un peu évolué par
exemple l'objectif européen est une
baisse de -1 55% des gaz à effet de
serre en 2030 est ce que la france va
tenir cet objectif
d'abord la france a des premiers
résultats nous l'avons vu sur
l'automobile et quand on compare les
émissions entre 2019 et 2020 c'est -13%
en une année sur la réduction grâce à
l'amélioration et au verdissement du
parc automobile donc les résultats
peuvent être rapides si les efforts sont
massifs et les efforts sans nassif sait
les efforts qui ont été consentis
engagée depuis 2007 et les efforts qui
sont encore amplifiées par les travaux
de la convention dont nous avons traduit
déjà l'essentiel par voie réglementaire
prend un exemple nous avions 42 mesure
dans les transports 25 sont déjà à
l'oeuvre et 14 sont intégrées dans le
projet de loi nous allons aller
évidemment encore plus loin les
transitions dans l'ensemble des secteurs
l'alimentation l'agriculture les
transports le logement sont en soit
absolument absolument massif entame
d'investissement savait que pour avoir
des résultats il faut concentrer les
efforts sur ce qui est produit le plus
de résultats je pense notamment à la
filière hydrogène pour nous qui va
concentrer à la fois des investissements
et l'engagement toutes les filières et à
ses conditions effectivement la force
non seulement peut être leader en europe
sur un certain nombre de nouvelles
filières et contribuer très massivement
et rapidement à l'atteinte de nos
objectifs environnementaux et donc les
efforts sur macif et cet objectif de
-55%
2030 il pourrait être atteint c'est
d'abord en politique l'optimisme et des
volontés comme on dit et dans les moyens
de cette volonté
nous avons investi au travail du plan de
relance et au travers tout et engagement
européen du crédit notamment des moyens
tout à fait considérable que nous allons
continuer à mener ces combats aux
niveaux national et européen pour que
ces objectifs soient effectivement à
terme des réalités et des résultats
tangibles pour nos concitoyens d'accord
vous êtes optimiste alors en revanche
les citoyens la convention citoyenne
pour le climat sont un peu pessimiste
sur ce projet loi climat qui est attiré
de leurs travaux d'ailleurs ils lui ont
mis une note de 2 5 sur 10 c'est un
lourd désaveu quand même pour le
gouvernement
écoutez vous savez nous avons reçu les
citoyens nous avons échangé de façon
très régulière avec eux ils ont jugé
l'action du gouvernement en toute
conscience beaucoup d'ennemis zéro-zéro
paraît parfois un peu comment dirais-je
voilà les et subjectif on appelle ça
comment comme on souhaite ce qui compte
c'est que maintenant le projet de loi
d'abord comme je les dis il intègre
énormément des propositions concrètes
qui ont été faites par les citoyens il
est aujourd'hui à la main du parlement
qui va le travail et le renforcer au nom
du peuple français ses sens de la
démocratie
et moi je ne doute pas encore une fois
que nous serons au rendez-vous des
résultats c'est ça qui compte
je peux quand même saluer l'exercice
démocratique tout à fait inédit de la
convention citoyenne qui a permis à 150
citoyens tirés au sort représentatifs
qui peuvent le français de se forger des
convictions et de faire des propositions
très concrètes dans un intérêt tout à
fait collectif et juste pour finir
rapidement gouvernement a quand même un
peu remanié ses propositions citoyennes
avec emmanuel macron avait promis le la
transmission sans fil trop parlement
gouvernement à respecter
parfois la lettre très souvent l'esprit
il a parfois aussi choisi de se donner
du temps sur les transitions industriel
quand vous savez que les secteurs sont
en profonde mutation que le coût social
les transformations est évidemment très
fort en temps de crise
gouverner c'est aussi décidé ces choix
nous les assumons et encore une fois le
parlement souverain jugera la suite
devenu à ce texte
oui la balle est dans le camp du
parlement merci beaucoup jean baptiste
des barriques neuves a répondu à ma
question
voilà pour cette interview de jean
baptiste djebbari enregistré il ya
quelques instants
dans un instant d'ailleurs nous allons
rejoindre et bien l'audition du ministre
de l'intérieur gérald darmanin et la
ministre chargée de la citoyenneté
marlène schiappa autour du projet de loi
comportant le respect des principes de
la république ce débrief est un donc un
petit peu écourtée mais en attendant et
bien on va à nouveau rejoindre quentin
quentin calmet dans l'hémicycle du sénat
car quand on disait il ya eu des
thématiques extrêmement variés cet après
midi dans l'hémicycle
il ya eu pas mal de questions aussi sur
et bien locaux vides et les vaccins
voilà la vaccination en particulier on a
entendu une question centriste sur une
possible 11e doses dans les flacons de
vaccin moderna et on sait que c'est ce
qui s'était déjà passé dans les flacons
de l'accent pfizer il était conditionnée
pour cinq doses et finalement ils
investissent dans ces flacons alors ce
serait peut-être la même chose avec le
vaccin moderna et bien écoutez la
réponse de brigitte bourguignon qui a
répondu sur ce sujet elle représentait
le ministère de la santé
aujourd'hui au moins des ministres et
elle a reconnu qu'une 11 m2 et est
possible d'écouter la afin de s'assurer
dans les meilleurs délais qui nous soit
possible d'exploiter éventuellement une
onzième dose et par anticipation
l'état a mis à disposition des
établissements de santé des centres de
vaccination du matériel adapté de rim
pour adapter à la récupération de la
11ème doses il s'agit de seringue
particulière nous anticipons donc cet
enjeu qui est primordial pour organiser
ces doses dont nous disposons et d'en
faire bénéficier bien sûr le plus grand
nombre dans les meilleurs délais voilà
c'est un peu comme ce qui s'est passé
avec le vaccin fader qui en train de se
passer peut-être on l'espère avec le
vaccin modern times
merci merci beaucoup quentin pour toutes
ces explications autour de la séance et
je le disais dans un instant eh bien on
va rejoindre l'audition
gérald darmanin et de marlène schiappa
tous deux sont auditionnés par la
commission des lois autour du projet de
loi sur le séparatisme le projet de loi
comportant le respect des principes de
la république
et puis à ce sujet bien on va rejoindre
alexandre poussard qui ce tour avec le
président du groupe union centriste
ici au sénat le sénateur hervé marseille
et oui juste avant les auditions du
gouvernement sur ce projet loi
séparatiste hervé marseille quelle va
être la position des sénateurs
centristes sur ce texte est ce qu'ils
vont suivre la droite sénatoriale sur
certaines positions notamment sur
l'interdiction du voile dans les sorties
scolaires ou à l'université
c'est les propositions des propositions
de la droite faut un peu vous rapprocher
écoutez il s'agit pas de suivre qui que
ce soit il s'agit simplement d'examiner
le texte nous avons reçu hier devant le
groupe
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin d'abord pour parler du premier
texte que nous examinons c'est à dire le
texte sécurité globale puisqu'on n'a pas
encore examiné celui là vous me parlez
de l'autre texte séparatisme qui va
venir dans quelques temps et ces deux
textes pour nous vont dans le bon sens
alors ça veut pas dire que nous
acceptons globalement tous les points
qui sont à l'intérieur mais on va
ailleurs que l'essentiel des points
contenus dans ces deux textes vont dans
un sens que nous approuvons alors il ya
un certain nombre de points qui font
discussions dans le point dans le texte
sécurité globale on va parler beaucoup
ici au sénat des polices municipales
c'est un problème territorial
je pense qu'on va trouver les voies de
compromis nécessaires et s'agissant du
texte séparatisme il reste quelques
points
j'allais dire à préciser mais pour ce
qui nous concerne ce sont des textes qui
vont dans le bon sens et sur lesquels
nous sommes globalement d'accord et pour
la loi séparatistes pour les sénateurs
centristes quel point doivent être à
préciser ce que ça concerne
l'encadrement de l'école à domicile
je pense que tout le monde d'accord
produire qu'il faut
permettre aux gens qui le souhaitent aux
familles qui le veulent de d'avoir un
enseignement à domicile je crois que
c'est acquis maintenant il faut pouvoir
encadrer ce droit parce qu'il s'agit pas
de laisser les enfants chez ceux on dit
qu'il ya des contrôles la vérité c'est
qu'il faut aller plus loin que ces
contrôles sont trop légers et que la
solution ses dans un meilleur contrôle
de la scolarité à domicile
et puis il ya tout le problème des
associations où il faut apporter là
aussi quelques précisions parce que on
vise les 1 mais il faudrait pas qu'on
touche tout le monde
donc je crois qu'il ya un encadrement
des contraintes des contrôles qu'il faut
préciser pour que le but recherché soit
atteint et que l'ensemble des cultes ne
soient pas pénalisés par une loi
nouvelle
merci beaucoup et remercie d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et les auditions
du gouvernement sur ce texte vont
commencer
[Musique]